يبدو ان فوائد السفر كثيره ومتنوعه نعدد
بعض هذه الفوائد لتعزيز صحتك النفسيه
المساعده على الشعور بالهدوء فالسفر ورؤيه
اماكن جديده يخفف من التوتر والضغط في
الحياه الاجتماعيه والمهنيه ويطيح للعقل
فرصه الاسترخاء والشفاء ويقلل من التعرض
للاكتئاب تحسين قوه العقل العقليه فتعلم
لغات جديده والذهاب الى اماكن جديده يفتح
العقل فالخروج من منطقه الراحه الخاصه بك
يمكن ان يكون مفيدا لصحتك العقليه كما
يمكن ان يساعد الابتعاد عن العمل على
الشعور بمزيد من الانتاجيه والتركيز عند
العوده لان العقل يحتاج الى وقتين للراحه
زياده الابداع يمكن الاشخاص الذين يسافرون
اكثر ابتكار افكار متنوعه والتعرض لتقطات
جديده وتكوين صدقات دوليه وتعلم لغات
جديده وتناول انواع مختلفه من الطعام
والموسيقى ويساعد على رؤيه العالم بطريقه
جديده دعم الحياه المهنيه والعائليه فبعد
السفر تشعر انك اكثر حيويه ومستعد لتحمل
كل ما ينتظرك في المنزل او العمل تقدير
قيمه المنزل فاختبار ثقافات اخرى مختلفه
من شانها ان يساعد على الشعور بالتقدير
اكثر لما يحيط بك عند عودتك الى المنزل